[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP très heureuse
de vous retrouver on va parler
alimentation agriculture écologie mais
aussi politique pendant 1 heure avec un
invité tout particulier cette semaine N
evons Alexis michaliic bonjour bonjour
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation avec moi vous le savez pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
montanis bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Alexis michaliic
bonjour Jean-Pierre vous êtes acteur
dramaturge metteur en scène scénariste
réalisateur et écrivain vous avez
remporté CIN Molières qui fait de vous
l'un des metteurs en scène les plus
jeunes jamais récompensé vous vous êtes
aussi lancé dans la comédie musicale
avec succès en mettant en scène les
producteurs vos cinq pièces attirent les
foules dès la première vous devenez un
artiste reconnu avec le porteur
d'histoire puis le cercle des
illusionnistes Edmond un tramuros et une
histoire d'amour vous avez fait de la
pièce Edmond un film et écrit en 2019
votre premier roman loin on vous a vu au
cinéma dans Sagan des gens qui
s'embrassent la vérité sur laffire
ilanaalimi ou dans la série Kabou
kitchen petit extrait de l'étendue de
vos talents alors à part ça on sait que
vous avez des origines polonaise par
votre papa et britannique par votre
maman et pourtant c'est en Afrique du
Nord que vous nous emmenez pour ce
déjeuner n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre oui et
je crois qu'il y a aussi des liens avec
le Maroc parce que c'est un couscous
royal et en dessert une salade de fruits
Brigitte dans le dessous des plats gros
plan sur les cuistau migrateurs une
association qui permet à des chefs
réfugiés en France de s'intégrer tout en
nous faisant partager leur tradition
culinaire dans les pieds dans le plat le
drave januari à la côte des restaurants
s metent et propose des accords mai 20
mA
120 allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
Alexis michalic vous qui aimez porter
les histoires voilà un compte planétaire
qui a du sens le jour où vous allez
évoquer à cette table votre pièce
passeport qui raconte le quotidien des
migrants de la jungle de calis c'est
l'histoire d'une petite graine le
couscous et oui afin d'être cohérent il
fallait aujourd'hui célébrer un plat qui
n'a besoin ni de passeport encore moins
de visa pour traverser les frontières
voilà pourquoi vous nous proposez ce
totem de la cuisine multiculture
universel inscrit au patrimoine
immatériel de l'Unesco d'origine berbère
il né au Maghreb mais n'a cessé de
s'enrichir au fil des ans avec les sorts
de la civilisation arabe des épices
comme la cannelle puis la viande vont
s'inviter dans la recette à partir du
11e siècle il séduit le Moyen-Orient en
France rabelet l'évoque dès 1542 mais
nous le découvrons vraiment dans les
années 60 après la gare d'Algérie grâce
aux vagues d'immigration venu d'Afrique
du Nord au point de figurer depuis
chaque année dans le top 5 de nos plats
préférés le couscous est-il un choix
politique de votre part vous pensez
sincèrement que la cuisine peut aider à
faire reculer les préjugés racistes et
la peur de
l'étranger si seulement si seulement ça
pouvait être le cas il me semble même
avoir le souvenir que certains députés
du RN ont eu des ennuis pour avoir mangé
un couscous c'estd de leur propre
électorat bien sûr même Jean-Marie Le
Pen je crois que c'est son plat préféré
d'aurs qu'on leur reprochait de d'aller
à l'ennemi donc étranger non c'est
surtout un choix gastronomique d'abord
parce que j'adore le couscous parce que
ce plat est fait avec des légumes
bouillis et c'est pas le pas le cas de
beaucoup de plats en France et puis
j'adore cette composition bon là on a
choisi un couscous royal donc avec
absolument toutes les viandes la totale
ce qui est un peu une hérésie pour les
pour mes amis marocains j'ai une copine
qui régulièrement me reproche de manger
des mergise avec le couscous parce que
ça n'est pas du tout normalement comme
ça qu'on pas du tout dans les codes du
du vrai couscous il y a pas il y a pas
de merguaise vous avez un souvenir
d'unun couscous d'enfance vous avez
votre premier couscous est-ce que vous
vous en souvenez par exemple non pas
particulièrement mais après je
rétorquerai quand même à cette à mon
amie que elle mange bien des sushis
California qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les sushis de base donc voilà une
culture elle elle s'additionne d'autres
cultures et puis c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à à cette magnifique assiette de
couscousse royale on va goûter parce
qu'il commence déjà un peu froid
regardez avec lesux depuis déjà il est
incroyable hein vous l'avez trouvé où
Brig alors c'est le restaurant
esessawira à Paris qui nous l'a
confectionné effectivement alors là
c'est le couscous royal vous pouvez
peut-être nous dire trois choses sur le
couscous royal par que c'estou même si
j'ai bien été spoyé par Alexis mais
c'est normal puisque c'est un fin
connaisseur et amoureux du couscous
alors symbole de sa parfaite intégration
le couscous royal est en fait une pure
invention française qui figure parfois
même à la carte de restaurant très
français qui le ment à la carte à côté
d'un BF bourguignon ou d'une blanquette
en en principe le couscous traditionnel
je parle sous le contrôle d'Alexis se
caractérise par une seule viande à cuire
mouton poulet beauf méchoui ou alors
poisson notamment en Tunisie où il y a
un couscous de poisson le couscous royal
lui porte bien son nom puisqu'il est
très riche en réunissant toutes ses
viandes dans un même plat sans oublier
le fameux mélange d'épices ras et
lanoute le couscous royal y ajoute donc
des boulettes et aussi ces fameuses
mergaises qui font hurler les puristes
de la graine qui parlent des vous avez
raison jamais en effet vous ne trouverez
une mergaise dans les trois couscous
différents du Maghreb l'Algérien le
Marocain et le Tunisien mais Alexis aime
les mergises donc on a un couscous royal
alors vous êtes en train de déguster ce
ce couscous on voit que ça vous fait
très très plaisir en tout cas et ça nous
fait du coup immensément plaisir mais
est-ce que vous le trouvez bon il est
pas mal il est il est il est pas très
chaud je vous le cache pas hein il est
un peu tiide mais ça c'est les
contraintes de l'émission évidemment
exactement mais malgré tout il est bon
j'ai rajouté une bonne dose d'arissa
pour pour vous aimez bien quand c'est un
petit peu relevé euh de plus en plus
ouais de plus en plus et il se trouve
que c'est vraiment le le plat de cet
hiver pour moi vraiment j'en ai mangé
peut-être allez un jour sur deux et mes
acteurs se se se moquent de moi parce
que voilà je suis obsédé par le couscous
mais je suis ravi de le partager
celui-là avec vous mais tous les
couscous ou c'est tous les deux jours
couscous royal non pas forcément Royal
ça dépend bah alors j'adore les mergage
effectivement donc effectivement je
trouve ça ça relève un petit peu le plat
il y a un petit côté épicé un petit peu
un petit peu piquant qui qui va
contraster avec la douceur de la sauce
avec les raisins d'ailleurs les raisins
aussi c'est pas forcément c'est un petit
ajout à nous he c'est pas c'est pas ah
il y a pas toujours des au Maroc il a
parfois ces petits raisins un peu sucrés
avec
ou et moi j'ai vécu effectivement
presque un an au Maroc en cumulé puisque
je je tournais dans une série qui
s'appelait le Kabul kitchen vous en
avvez parlé tout à l'heure et qui se
tournait à Casablanca donc donc là
c'était marrant tous les jours alors
c'était Maroc tous les jours mais
c'était pas couscous tous les jours
parce que le couscous c'est pas non plus
c'est en fait le couscous au Maroc c'est
un truc familier
c'est le plat de famille c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on va manger dans les
resto c'est un plat de F auss ça se
partage oua bah c'est un plat du du
vendredi soir enfin c'est un plat de
c'est un plat de du moment où on se
retrouve et et là-bas on le mange à la
main ou pas forcément non pas forcément
pas la tradition tradition ancestrale
quoià non non mais mais en tout cas
voilà c'est c'est le plat de famille
chacun a son couscous toutes les
familles ont leur couscous chaque maman
a son couscous vous mangez des tajines
des pastillass tagines ouais c'est
plutôt tajine qu'on va manger dans les
dans les resto effectivement que je
mangeais au Maroc la salade de carottes
au cumin voilà effectivement le du cumin
un peu partout j' que le cumin j'ai
adoré puis j'en ai trop mangé donc
maintenant j'ai un petit ah ou ouais ça
c'est trop de cumin trop de cumin
tuulcumain ils en mettent absolument sur
toutes les viandes et cetera donc mais
là il y a pas de rejet un peu du
couscous si vous en mangez aussi souvent
vous AZ pas un peu à au bout d'un moment
j'en ai pas trop mangé à bas mais je
pense que le couscous on ne s'en lasse
jamais parce que d'abord les légumes
alors moi ce qui fait le un bon couscous
pour moi c'est la variété des légumes
vous remarquez que là il y a pas de
céleri non or le céleri c'est un petit
peu la facilité du couscousier chip
parce que le célleri c'est pas trop cher
on en met plein et donc quand vous
recevez un couscous et qu'il y a plein
de céléri en général bon c'est bah c'est
que c'est c'est que c'est c'est que ça
coûte moins cher que que là où on voit
qu'il y a bien beaucoup cour carottes
des courgettes nav nav parfois dans les
couscous d'hiver il y a des courges
aussi il y a du petit Ron parfois et
puis il y a parfois quelqu alors ça
c'est des variantes du coup bah dans le
Magreb et parfois il y a alors c'est un
peu oublié en France on en mangeait
beaucoup à Lyon c'est le cardon et dans
certains couscous magrébiens il y a du
Cardon espèce de plante un peu une tige
un peu dure qui se cuisine à Lyon on le
faisait en gratin et c'est souvent on le
retrouve dans les couscous dans certains
couscous au Maghreb je savais pas mais
non non voilà c'est c'est moi je le
trouve bon hein je trouve que les
viandes sont bonnes et effectivement ils
souffrent d'être un peu tiède mais c'est
un bon couscous c'est donc une bonne
adresse une bonne adresse le seul truc
c'est qu'il y a en général beaucoup de
sucre dans la sauce ce serait parfait ce
serait hyper diète mais dans la sauce
elle est très sucrée donc c'est un peu
calorique c'est ce que vous nous dites
le calorique si jamais on on rajoute
comme moi de louche de sauce à chaque
fois et c'est c'est un plat que vous
aviez l'habitude de manger quand vous
étiez petit je sais pas si vos parents
faisaient à la maison ou vous l'avez
découvert plus tard je l'ai vraiment
découvert plus tard et et aujourd'hui je
vis une une belle histoire d'amour avec
AC couscous exactement et alors est-ce
que vous savez le préparer parce que
c'est quand même tout un truc de faire
le couscous surtout la semoule il faut
il y a tout un savoir-faire derrière
vous avez appris ça vous intéresse moi
je suis vraiment une quiche en cuisine
donc pour ça qu'on vous a invité
d'ailleurs absolument et c'est pour ça
parce que je je je cherche à me nourrir
et donc merci de m'accueillir pour
connaître vos astuces vos petits trucs
exactement donc non je je je n'ai jamais
préparé un couscous de ma vie mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose à faire
une fois ou au moin est-ce que vous avez
déjà vous savez faire le couscousors moi
j'avoue que je ne sais pas faire le cous
alors moi je l'ai un peu appris j'arrive
pas à faire de la smoule fine de la
smoule moyenne c'est souvent un travail
de femme alors je sais pas siil faut
voir le patriarcat mais c'est vrai que
c'est souvent les femmes qui roulent la
smoule alors il faut un C couchier alors
après on peut se débrouiller mais
effectivement il faut qu'il y ait
plusieurs cuisson trois il faut que la
vapeur monte et après il faut mélanger
on se brûle les doigts surtout parce que
avec en mettant les mains dans le fr il
faut séparer les et puis rajouter alors
ce que m'avait dit des cuisinières qui
connaissaient bien le couscous à la fin
il faut plutôt mettre de l'huile d'olive
que du beurre si on veut garder la
semoule parce que le beurre peut rencir
un petit peu si on la garde quelques
jours alors que l'huile d'olive est ne
prend pas de petit goût voilà ça c'est
une petite astuce bon type bon type
alors donc si vous êtes pas en cuisine
vous par exemple si vous êtes chez vous
qui a rien à manger euh vous savez quand
même vous prépareer un un œuf au plat
vous ouvrez une boîte de conserve com
bien sûr bien sû non non mais je je je
sais faire le minimum nécessaire mais il
se trouve que moi je je voilà je je suis
beaucoup resto je suis beaucoup dehors
je je j'ai je suis toujours avec des
amis j'ai une grande bande de pot euh
donc je si je suis pas au resto je je
commande beaucoup à manger à tel point
que une une célèbre enseigne une célèbre
app de livraison de nourriture m'a déjà
proposé par deux fois des solutions pour
mon entreprise alors que je n'ai pas
d'entreprise c'est juste moi qui
commande de la nourriture c'est dire à
quel point je commande souvent pour des
grandes tablées donc voilà peut-être
qu'il voudrait vous avoir vous comme
figure pour vendre leur entreprise de
ils ont pas besoin de vooir comme figure
je pense que ma consommation suffit déjà
à leur faire à peu près 30 % de leur
chiffre d'affair et vous faites partie
de la nouvelle génération vous êtes
jeune vous êtes devriez déconstru ce
point V là non gentil vous êtes gentil à
quel niveau au niveau de la cuisine oui
oui ça a rien à voir avec un quelconque
sexisme mais plutôt avec mes habilités
personnelles vous êtes mais vous êtes
gourmand vous AZ pas envie de vous dire
tiens il faut que je le fasse moi-même
il faut que vous avez pas de temps parce
que vous avez beaucoup trop de boulot
avec vos théâtre vos
cinémas non je pense que si en fait si
parce que moi vous faites plaisir à voir
là vous êtes un des rares invités qui
qui se souci de plaisir on a
l'impression que vous prenez vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir moi je pense surtout
à la Régie son qui doit avoir un un
grand plaisir à pouvoir entendre tous
les
bruitation mais mais peu me chaud il
fallait pas m'inviter à manger à CCOS
voilà est-ce que vous avez de bonnes
adresses à conseillé à nos
téléspectateurs en matière de de
couscous ou restaurant oui alors moi
j'ai mon petit prfque du Nord Voilà il
se trouve que on va parler de passeport
bien sûr qui se joue au théâtre de la
Renaissance à Strasbourg- saintnis et à
Strasbourg saintnis il y a le le becf au
becf chez Saï juste à côté et qui est
voilà c'est vraiment gratos mais je
l'aime particulièrement l'assaut c'est
gratos hein si nos téléspectateurs il
vont il va quand même falloir payer il
va falloir payer un petit coup de pubce
c'était complètement inendu c'est mon
PEP pr effectivement des fois je me fais
livrer chez eux des fois j'y vais ils
ont un couscous méchoui c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas une pièce c'est c'est un
espèce de pavé énorme délicieux grillé
comme il faut enfin voilà au becf chez
sa et toute la troupe aime partager le
couscous parce que sinon vous leur
imposez ça un jour sur des orill des
forces non de force ils sont obligés de
absolument bon on varie un peu des fois
mais mais parfois on va aller chercher
thaille parfois on va aller chercher
libanais et puis couscous c'est comme
ils savent que c'est ma passion voilà
que j'aime pas manger seul donc je
régale un peu tout alors on a compris
que vous étiez le roi de la mergaise
mais il faut pas oublier dans le
couscous le poisson aussi parce que il y
a les viandards en Tunisie il y a le
couscous de poisson et il y a le
couscous aux poulpes vous avez déjà
goûté du couscous aux poulpes non ça
c'est sur l'île de carneral à la carnéal
la grande île tunisienne je crois que je
prononce pas très bien d'ailleurs mais
là il y a un poulpe au couscous et il y
a un couscous de poisson ben je non
jamais goûté alors moi le poupe on le
c'est vrai poupe on le faisait autrement
parce que figurez-vous que quand j'étais
euh quand j'étais jeune quand j'étais
jeune quand j'étais gamin on allait en
vacances en Grèce souvent avec mes
parents tous les étés et euh et moi je
pêchais le poulpe euh avec mon petit
masque et mon tuba et ma mère préparait
un le ce qu'on appelle octapodis
titifado en grec c'est-à-dire une espèce
de poulpe à l'étouffé avec des oignons
tout ça et donc on mangeait le fruit de
de la pêche donc c'est comme ça qu'on
composait le poulpe et mon père qui est
artiste peintre euh plasticien il
utilisait le poup pu il prenait des des
des morceaux de il prenait sa propre
encre il l'a macéré dans son ancre et il
est plaqué pardon excusez-moi c'est le
couscous hamdouah c'est sur des grandes
toiles blanches et il arrivait à faire
le il arrivait à faire des œuvres en
utilisant le poup donc ce poup était
entièrement utilisé l'encre de seche
quasiment l'encre de poulpe donc
absolument qui est un poê différente que
l'encre de sèche mais qui est non moins
efficace et et et voilà donc le poupe
avait un cycle complet d'utilisation
mais je connais pas le couscous tout la
famille c'est l'île de carkena en
Tunisie où il y a ce fameux couscous
alors vous nous avez parlé de beaucoup
de cuisine du monde là mais pas du tout
la cuisine traditionnelle française la
bonne cuisine du du terroir elle vous
plaît elle vous plaît moins celle-là ou
vous êtes lassé en fait je pense que j'y
ai été moins habitué euh ne serait-ce
que parce que mes parents ont des ma
mère est anglaise et
elle cuisinait non pas de la cuisine
traditionnelle anglaise mais de la
cuisine méditerranéenne mes parents se
sont rencontrés en Grèce dans les années
70 et je pense qu'ils ont toujours eu
une âme à la fois de voyageur et de et
d'ouverture
culinaire et et de manière générale au
monde donc effectivement ma mère elle
adore cuisiner plutôt des baclavas des
plats méditerranéens des tomates farciis
des trucs qui viennent plutôt de poiv
FARC ou exactement et la cuisine
anglaise c'était plutôt ma grand-mère
anglaise donc chez qui on allait à Noël
et là là qu'est-ce qu'elle préparait
làors ouais parce que cuisine du
français chauin ça existe la gastronomie
britannique bien sûr ouais ouais be be
c'est des c'est une dinde rôtie avec par
exemple des légumes rôtis des panets des
des carottes moi l'un de mes plats
préférés c'est un plat anglais qui était
un gigot d'agneau avec deux sauces une
sauce d'glacé et une sauce à la menthe
voilà la sauce à si vous avez jamais
mangé ça je vous le conseille c'est un
délice cet alliage déjà l'agneau c'est
une de mes viandes préférées l'agneau
avec une petite sauce d'glacé une petite
sauce à Lamande des patates rotis c'est
ext des haricots verts bien sûr c'est
extraordinaire la gastronomie anglaise
existee alors la gastronomie
il y a des il y a des choses qu'onon
peut découvrir ici sûement c'est plus
riche que la que c'est votre papa
cuisère mon grand-père est arrivé de
Pologne il avait 2 ans donc il est il il
a émigré enfin son père a émigré de
Pologne en 1926 donc du coup il a il a
grandi en France donc il y avait pas une
une tradition culinaire polonaise très
ancrée en tout cas elle est pas arrivée
jusqu'à ma génération mon père a ils ont
ils sont implantés dans le nord vers
maobug dans une région où il y avait pas
grand-chose à vrai dire pre agriculteur
et euh et et donc il y a quelques plats
du Nord qui ont survécu un peu donc mon
père faisait un mon père cuisine lui
très bien il fait un fricot de chou
rouge de temps en temps j' dire le chou
ou exactement fricot de chou rouge avec
vraiment des patates des grosses
saucisses un truc qui tient bien au donc
un plat div en général euh et c'est à
peu près tout et et à part ça j'ai j'ai
pas vraiment de lien avec la cuisine
traditionnelle on mangeait pas vraiment
de la blanquette on mangeait pas
vraiment des des plats donc j'ai
toujours eu cette cet amour de la de de
l'extérieur de des des cuisines du monde
de C curiosité en tout cas vers les
cuisines étrang autre et l'Asie parce
que là on a parlé de l'Afrique du Nord
là vous êtes alors là on a compris et
puis la GR califor rô ouis tout et
l'Asie aussi vous êtes ouais bah l'Asie
moi pareil à dos c'était un peu les
premiers restaurants sushi hein on a
j'ai découvert les sushis c'était pas
comme aujourd'hui où c'est il y en a
partout c'était vraiment un truc un peu
particulier de d'aller manger des sushis
au tout début et j'ai évidemment adoré
et encore une fois ilétait très ouvert
et et aujourd'hui moi je je je suis fan
de de toute de de toutes ces de toutes
ces gastronomie Chine
Vietnam ou ouais il y a je connais une
une entrepreneur qui s'appelle cine
Chong qui a créé Bao family à Paris ou
plein de restaurants bah délicieux
j'adore il y a non je moi je je je me je
me régale et et et par-dessus tout ce
que j'aime c'est le c'est les le côté un
peu MZ tap pass quoi hein j'adore j'ai
j'ai du mal Ave
absolument ouais puis même pourûter qu
ouais ouais moi je je je suis allé
beaucoup de fois au Liban donc la
cuisine libanaise je suis allé aussi
beaucoup de fois en Israël qui a qui est
qui est très qui est similaire sur plein
d'aspects euh toutes ces cuisines
méditerranéennes qui mettent qui mettent
à l'honneur le légume qui rendent le
légume un peu sexy hein où vraiment on
utilise des aubergines on utilise des
patates douces et et on y rajoute
énormément de sauce ça je j'ai découvert
qu'on pouvait manger végétarien et
pourtant que ce soit un un mélange de
saveur extraordinaire j'ai un conseil
pour vous je pense que Brigitte sera
d'accord avec moi achetez les livrees
d'autolengi et mettez-vous à la cuisine
si vous croyez que je l'ai pas déjà
cuisinez pas si je fais quelques
quelques
cuillers non mais j'exagère je dis que
je fais pas le couscous mais quand même
je sais faire de trois trucs gelet
simple
d' pas si simple que ça
mais c'est vrai quand même mais mais il
y a en tout cas plein de recett tout
cette inspiration israélienne turque
c'est assz intéressant est-ce que vous
FA faites attention quand vous consommez
de dire bah il faut que je mange moins
de viande là il y a beaucoup de viande
dans ce plat là parce que c'est moins
bien pour le climat parce que pour des
raisons écologique ou pour des raisons
de bien-être animal ou les les légumes
que vous aimez ce que vous dites bon
faut que je consomme plus de bio de
local tout ça ou je pense que de base et
c'est ironique de dire ça alors que je
suis en train de faire la fête à
scouscous mais je suis pas un gros
viandard quand je vais au restaurant je
je vais pas commander de la viande rouge
c'est pas mon premier truc je pense que
la viande que je consomme le plus c'est
clairement du poulet ouais euh et eu et
non et je suis et j'adore le soir
pouvoir manger des légumes et que des
légumes ça me convient très bien sauf
que bon en restauration c'est assez
difficile de trouver des plats de plus
en plus hein on peut trouver des plats
végétariens et cetera mais quand même
c'est vrai que quand on arrive dans un
resto on a plutôt tendance à avoir des
frites et du riz que que que une vraie
variété de plats à base de légumes et et
pourtant je suis persuadé et je pense
que c'est notorité publique la santé de
tout le monde s'emporterait mieux on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment un col
c'est le
quiz donc avec ce sang britannique qui
coule dans vos veines Alexis vous êtes
sans doute accro au fish and chips
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses a le
plus vieux commerce de fish and chips
référencé a ouvert en 1860 dans l'est de
Londres oui ça me semble tout à fait
vrai oui vrai mais Manchester Dundy et
Dublin revendiquent aussi bien sûr la
paternité du fish and chips la friture
comme technique de conservation du
poisson frais et d'origine
ottomane dire c'est vrai non c'est faux
c'est d'origine juive c'est mentionné
dans un livre de cuisine anglais du 18e
siècle pas de fish and chip sans patate
bien sûr dont la culture arrive d'abord
en Irlande bon est-ce que c'est vrai ou
faux ou moi j'aurais tendance à dire que
c'est c'est en Belgique mais bon je vais
peut-être me tromper alors c'est alors
je parlais du Royaume-Uni là Royaume-Uni
alors oui c'est possible ouis oui c'est
possible et c'est arrivé et ensuite en
Grande-Bretagne au début du 19e siècle
bah c'était les plus pauvres les
Irlandais donc la culture de Patat est
arrivé d'abord entre les deux guerres
qui est l'âge d'or du fish and chips
l'aigle fin était le poisson roi qui
était consommé dans ces commerces
l'aigle fin je sais que c'est le code
mais je sais pas la
traduction c'est l'lopin le code ou pas
non c'est du cabillot non voilà c'était
le cabillot bravo ça fait combien trois
réponses sur qure de just
ouis c'est pas mal attendez deuxème quiz
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment très
fort les hommes de théâtre sont friants
de tirad ciselé mais aussi de bonne
cuisine sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses à le
parmesan était le fromage préféré de
Molière parmeson le parmesan vrai ou
faux ça me semble ça me semblerait
étonnant quand même déjà du parmeson
c'est vrai c'est vrai comment incroyable
Jean-Pierre vous êtes sûr de votre
réponse qui vous a dit ça qui vous a dit
que le
parage parlez pas au momentù je suis en
train d'ingérer la boulette si justement
c'est plus drôle à quel moment à quel
moment trouve c'est une boulette
Jean-Pierre comment vous le savez alors
je l'ai lu et je l'ai vu mais c'est pas
étonnant parce que le parmesan est un
très vieux fromage italien à cette
époque les les ma circulaient déjà il y
avait pas forcément de mondialisation et
encore mais c'est pour me lire le
fromage
préféré Shakespeare considérait que le
thé était la boisson reine vrai ou faux
ça m'étonnerait parce que le thé à
priori ça vient d'un non donc c'est un
peu plus tard faux la bière la bière
évidemment la bière bien sûr il appelait
le ma des rois des RO c'était son
expression bien sûr bien sûr mais
c'était beaucoup plus sûr à l'époque de
boire de la bière que de boire de l'eau
on avait beaucoup moins de chance
d'attraper une maladie et donc tout le
monde était à priori au Moyen-Âge tout
le monde était bourré le soir vraiment
ben c'est sûr on consommait plus de
bière que d'eau ou le vin ou le vin des
grandes expéditions partait comme
magelin on mettait du vin dans les sout
parce qu'on savait que le vin avec
l'alcool ça tuéit tous les en revanche
le thé c'est vraiment ma
boisson que du thé froid chaud à tous
les repas à tous les repas ouais ouais
j'ai j'ai chez moi des je je me fais
parce que je je bois pas d'alcool et du
coup ben de tout lesété mais je je me
fais des grandes infusions soit infusion
soit thé moi j'aime le leget le matin
mais ça c'est voilà vos origines Brit
puis après il été parfumés il y en a
plein puis juste je les fait refroidir
je les mets dans des dans des dans des
grandes carafes et tous les amis savent
que froid parfois avec un petit peu de
un petit peu de menthe un petit peu de
un petit un petit trondel de citron donc
et sens donc mes amis savent que quand
ils viennent chez moi ils ouvrent le
frigo il y a des jares de thé froids
quoi alors on poursuit avec le canard
qui a été une viande détestée par Victor
Hugo vrai ou faux ça je sais pas mais je
vais dire oui allez et ben non faux
c'était même son péché mignon il adorait
le canard Victor Hugo ça c'est un peu
gras quand même le canard j'ai un peu du
mal avec le canard canard ça sent un peu
quand on le prépare à la maison c'est
dit pas n'importe quoi le canard c'est
pas très gras c'est une viande
simplement la peau de canard si elle est
grasse mais on peut l'enlever le Magra
si vous enlevez le gras c'est une viande
qui est tout à fait maigre gr pasér
après vous pouvez c'est le gras qui va
donner ce goût je suis bien d'accord
avec vous mais sachez aussi pour la
petite histoire que c'est quand même un
bon gras il vaut mieux manger de la peau
de canard que de la graisse de por non
non c'est je sais que le lobby du canard
P TR cher cette émission pas dans le lob
du canard
ça il y a des recettes scientifiques sur
le foie gras par exemple et et la
graisse de canard est a un peu les mêmes
vertus que l'huile d'olive donc manger
de la graisse de canard et manger du
canard S la canard vraiment besoin d'une
sieste de 3 He
ça
quoiif que les autres je veux pas vexer
les canards mais bon voilà bon bah voilà
ça a pourri l'ambiance on continue
Alexandre Duma était fan du poulet à la
ficelle recette qu'il avait lui-même
inventé poulet à la ficelle poulet à la
ficelle alors je je sais pas pour le
poulet à la ficelle je sais pour
l'omelette aux huîres dont il était fan
parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai oui j'ai ma
mère est grande fan d'Alexandre Duma et
je lui ai offert un bouquin qui sont les
recettes d'Alexandre Duma vous pouz le
trouver ouais dans dans le commerce où
il raconte un peu toutes ces vous AZ pas
vu si cette poule à la ficelle était
dans ce livre je vais dire que ça doit y
être alors non et ben c'est vrai ben
c'est vrai le poulet à la ficelle donc
quoi qu'est-ce qu'
entouré le suspendait et puis tous les
orifices étaient bouchés et cousu et
cetera il le pendait le croupillon en
l'air ouis c'était un gros gros
mangeurour mangeait dans des proportions
différentes à l'époque il y avait alors
c'est souvent autour de la table que se
que se raconent les meilleures histoires
que se fait aussi la petite et la grande
hoire et c'est la breve de
comptoir Alexis Michalik on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une anecdote
autour d'un repas est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter quelque chose j'aurais
bien aimé vous trouvez une anecdote
autour d'un repas parce que c'est c'est
ma passion le repas je tiens j'en ai
j'en ai 1000 mais j'ai pas d'anecdote
particulièrement politique en revanche
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
et c'est peut-être un segment vers ma
pièce passeport puisque la plupart du
temps c'est c'est autour de la table que
les sujets politiques arrivent et que
les engueulades arrivent aussi hein qui
n'a pas été au cours d'une fête de
famille dans une enguelade avec une
génération différente souvent avec des
points de vues un peu différents l'un un
peu plus réactionnaire l'autre un peu
plus progressiste euh bon en général je
suis du côté progressiste et et là dans
passeport l'une des scènes centrale on
va dire de la pièce ça commence ça parle
des réfugiés de l'arrivée des réfugiés
en France mais ça parle aussi de l'autre
côté et on va suivre un gendarme qui
s'appelle Lucas qui est noir et qui est
né à Mayotte mais qui a été adopté par
un couple de calésiens Michel et
Christine et et Michel est un ancien
militaire un petit peu raide un petit
peu un petit peu réac peut-être Unac et
euh Lucas donc ce jeune gendarme va
rencontrer une journaliste qui s'appelle
Jeanne et qui est noir aussi de parents
malien mais qui a grandi en France et
qui est beaucoup plus politisé qui a
déjà fait son son chemin un petit peu
vers l'identité et qui va pousser Lucas
à se poser quelques questions parce que
lui il est un petit peu neutre sur le
sujet ayant grandit à Calais dans un
environnement principalement blanc et un
jour il l'amène à table avec la jingle
de Calais aussi mais absolument lui il
est lui il est gendarme à la jingle de
Calais et son job c'est de retenir les
réfugiés qui essayent d'en sortir et de
passer en Angleterre c'est le seul la
seule fonction des des gendarmes et des
CRS qui s'y trouvent à ce moment-là et
un soir il amène Jeane à dîner pour la
présenter à ses parents donc Michel et
Christine en ayant omis de dire à Michel
que Jeanne était noir aussi et et Michel
va se retrouver un peu perturbé et va
s'enivre une discussion autour de la
table sur le sujet de l'immigration h je
vous laisse imaginer quels arguments
chaque camp va avoir Jeanne ayant un peu
étudié le sujet elle va démonter un peu
les idées reçues de Michel à grand coup
de de chiffres et d'exactitude et puis
et puis du coup c'est une sorte de
métaphore enfin pas de métaphore mais
d'exemple même d'une conversation qu'on
peut retrouver si tenta qu'en face de de
de ces de ces idées reçu habituelles on
est vraiment une source documentée et et
très claire sur ce qu''est l'immigration
sur ce qu'elle apporte à la société et
et sur et sur ses bienfaits et et son
aspect positif alors ça se termine
comment ce repas entre jeen et Lucas et
bien le ton monte et pour savoir comment
ça se termine il faudra venir voir la
pièce passeport alors vous nous faites
une transition formidable vous avez
écrit mis en scène cette pièce passeport
au Théâtre de la Renaissance qui se joue
depuis le 26 janvier à Paris où Issa
donc un jeune héritréen laissé pour mort
dans la jungle de Calais entame une
longue quête afin d'obtenir un titre de
séjour ça seule mémoire et le passeport
qu'il porte sur lui dans cette pièce
vous avez un partenaire qui est
l'association des cuistau migrateurs
l'occasion donc de parler de
l'intégration par la cuisine et c'est le
dessous des
plats Brigit il viennent effectivement
d'Afghanistan d'Irak de Syrie du Mali du
Sri Lanka arrivé en France après les
périples de plusieurs mois aujourd'hui
c'estes réfugiés au talents de chef de
cuisiniers font partager leurs
traditions culinaires et leur culture au
sein de de ces cuistau migrateurs
service traiteur mais aussi école de
cuisine solidaire écologique tout ça est
né en 2015 et c'est un reportage à
Montreuil de Clément perouau et de Cléa
joanau le monde entier dans une cuisine
chez les cuisto migrateurs traiteur
événementiel installé à Montreuil tous
les chefs et tous les cuisiniers sont ou
ont été des demandeurs
d'asile chacun est venu ici avec sa
recette pour composer une carte
hérocliteen les oignons et le
sel
marjch en SAU c'est
bon les cuistau migrateurs se présentent
comme une entreprise sociale ici tous
les cuisiniers réfugiés sont embauchés
en CDI ou CDD tu tu en es où là sur
l'idée est d'aider à leur intégration en
leur fournissant un travail fixe bon
courage c'est une idée qui nous est
venue à l'automne 2015 on a vraiment
tout simplement été rattrapé par la par
l'actualité la crise migratoire devenait
un sujet quotidien les migrants toujours
présentés comme comme un poids comme une
menace c'est une question complexe mais
nous on a voulu vraiment montrer qu'il y
avait du positif dans tout ça qu'on
pouvait créer du positif à partir du
moment on donnait la chance aux gens de
de montrer ce qu'ils apportaient plat
exotique fibr social la recette est
gagnante de plus en plus d'entreprises
font appel au cuisto migrateur pour
leurs cocktail et buffets et depuis 4
ans ils ont aussi monté une école de
cuisine basé sur le même concept 200
élèves tous réfugiés suivent les cours
aujourd'hui la séance de travaux Prati
porte sur la préparation d'une pâte à
nouille aglomère on réunit vous chacun
une balance 200 g de farine de par
personne une grosse pincée de sel
beaucoup de ces élèves n'étaient pas
cuisinés avant d'arriver en France comme
Maya syrienne j'étais
journaliste j'ai décidé de lancer en
cuisine c'est culturel c'est le
partage voilà ils sont très attentifs
ils sont motivés leur niveau de français
est assez bon ils ont eu un mois de
français intensif avec une prof avant
d'arriver en cuisine mais une fois
qu'ils auront leur titre ou même sans
leur titre ils pourront aller sur le
terrain ils pourront vite vite à choper
un poste et du coup ensuite d'avoir un
appartement et tout ce qui s'enuit quoi
oui effectivement s'intégré à la France
85 % des élèves trouvent un emploi
durable à la sortie de cette formation
alors Alexis comment vous avez découvert
les cuistau migrateurs ça remonte à
quelques années à leur naissance ou
c'est rent non oh bah je vous cache pas
que en fait au moment où on a on a mis
la pièce en chantier euh il se trouve
que donc on va suivre Issa cette ce
réfugié éitréen et et sa tentative
d'intégration en France et puis euh bah
quand on a pas encore de papier il y a
pas 1000 options et donc il y a
plusieurs possibilités ils peuvent
travailler sur des chantiers bon au noir
ils peuvent se retrouver à à travailler
euh dans des entreprises de livraison de
nourriture ils peuvent et souvent ils se
retrouvent en cuisine euh donc Isa et
ses amis vont se retrouver en cuisine et
vont être dans l'univers de la
restauration et apporter aussi leur leur
leurs origines leur culture au au monde
de la cuisine et finalement peut-être
ouvrir un restaurant euh donc on s'est
dit ce serait ce serait chouette de de
tendre la main à des associations ou en
tout cas à des à des à des associations
ou des entreisuctures desructure qui qui
qui vont un peu dans le sens de la pièce
histoire d'avoir un accompagnement à la
sortie pour que les gens en sortant de
la pièce qui se disent tiens ce sujet
m'a touché qu'est-ce que je peux faire
moi ou vers qui je peux me tourner où on
est on est des pistes de réflexion donc
on a un partenariat avec le musée de
l'immigration ce qui est ce qui est
super et et ensuite benah effectivement
le le ça nous semblait logique d'amener
les cuistos migrateurs hein puisque dire
quoi qui propose en en tout cas une
alimentation à la sortie du du théâtre
voilà bon déjà ils vont faire le pot de
le pot ils ont fait le pot de première
mais mais mais ouais dans l'idée ils
vont mettre en place toute façon il y a
toujours une un petit un petit bar au
théâtre et on va pouvoir vendre des
planches truc comme ça avec avec leur
avec pas de la
charcuterieien est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce que vous avez mangé c'est
bon oui oui c'est délicieux après bon
moi il a y a les goûts personnels
c'estàd que là il parle de des
branchettes d'Anette avec l'Iran bon moi
l'anette je peux pas mais mais il y a
plein de trucs ouais c'est comme ça mais
non il y a il y a plein de trucs il y a
plein de trucs super bon c'est c'est un
mélange de plat de de de simple mais de
plein de plein de je crois que le
chiffre 8 c'est le chiffre symbole des
cistau migrateur parce que je crois
qu'il y a h cultures h qui sont
représentés par les recettes culinaires
la la cuisine c'est un c'est peut-être
le meilleur moyen d'intégration pour
vous en FR encore une fois j'aimera
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien que ce
soit le meilleur moyen d'intégration on
s'en est un en tout cas c'est sûr mais
et pour eux c'est l'une des leur seules
option on a vu d'ailleurs voilà l'une
des l'une des filles du reportage qui
dit moi j'étais journaliste en Syrie et
maintenant je suis cisto et c'est le cas
de beaucoup de réfugiés et c'est encore
une idée reçue à combattre c'est c'est
cette idée de de qu'ils arrivent et
qu'en fait ils sont pas qualifiés si si
ils sont tout à fait qualifiés pour la
plupart simplement après faut maîtriser
la langue maîtriser la langue ce qui a
une grosse barrière et puis voilà faut
pas oublier que les les les réfugiés qui
qui veulent passer en Angleterre qui se
retrouvent à Calais en tout cas dans
dans dans dans ma pièce et c'est ceux
qui justement n'ont pas la langue
française et c'est pour ça qu'ils
veulent passer en Angleterre soit pour
rejoindre soit pour rejoindre leur
famille soit tout simplement parce
qu'ils parlent anglais euh et
l'Angleterre paye la France pour les
empêcher de passer donc il se retrouvve
un peu dans une situation où après avoir
traversé euh
milliers de kilomètres en fait ils sont
bloqués à Calais et ils sont bien
obligés de se dire bon qu'est-ce que je
fais il va falloir que j'apprenne la
langue et c'est le début de du parcours
du combattant mais la jeune syrienne
elle est journaliste mais elle se met à
la cuisine mais elle est enthousiaste
elle a l'air passionnée elle dit c'est
formidable transmet non mais ils peuvent
aussi se réaliser dans ce métier bien
sûr bien sûr je je
l'espère mais c'est vrai que quand on
est docteur en Syrie ou architecte en
irac et qu'on se retrouve cisto c'est
vrai que ça peut être V vous imaginez
vous retrouvez dans un pays dont vous
met isez pas la langue parce que ben en
fait la guerre a éclaté ici et que vous
êtes parti sur les routes sans savoir si
vous allez revenir un jour et vous
retrouvez dans un pays à vous dire bon
bah qu'est-ce qu' me reste à faire et
ben je va faire la cuisine moi je pareil
sur Jean-Pierre c'est le meilleur
d'entre nous il va se mettre en cuisine
dans n'importe quel pays je peut-être
même plus
heureux la cuisine si on n pas
effectivement si on n pas à la plonge et
si on est cuisiné si on peut faire
transmettre son son c'est un pétier
passionnant on le voit bien quand on on
reçoit des grands chefs ce sont des
garçons passionnés et on sent dans les
yeux de cette petite sirienne qu'elle
est passionnée par son nouveau métier
évidment évidemment alors je vous
propose qu'on regarde un petit extrait
justement des des répétitions de votre
pièce
[Musique]
passeport
on va l'écouter pe peu plus tard mais
dites-nous pourquoi vous avez décidé de
traiter ce sujet de l'immigration c'est
pas forcément facile et puis on est dans
une actualité très forte en ce moment
justement sur ce thème là je déjà je
parle jamais d'un thème donc je me suis
je me suis pas dit tiens je vais parler
de ça je vais parler d'immigration je
vais parler d'éfugier je par toujours de
l'histoire et et l'histoire m'est
arrivée il y a 3 ans j'étais en
Guadeloupe et et j'ai j'ai eu la l'idée
de la fin de la pièce que donc je vais
pas dévoiler évidemment mais mais cette
fin m'a fait remonter un peu le de cette
histoire et la construire à robourg et
et je me suis dit mais en fait il
faudrait que ça commence dans la jungle
de Calais qui était un endroit que je ne
connaissais pas très bien euh enfin pas
plus que ce que tout le monde croit
savoir vous êtes allé sur place je suis
pas allé sur place parce qu'elle a été
démantelée moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'était la période 2015- 2016 au pic de
son de sa fréquentation he si on peut
dire où il y avait entre 6000 et 10000
réfugiés mais j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à lire à la fois des
témoignages des sites des des des
bouquins sur le sujet sur sur Calais sur
euh sur le sur les réfugiés sur
l'immigration en France et l'immigration
en général dans le monde et euh et au
fur et à mesure ce se dessiner un peu le
une pensée plus précise de des sujets
que je voulais aborder et puis au début
d'une histoire simple de suivre un
réfugi c'est devenu quelque chose de
plus large et d'essayer d'aborder un
prisme de de on va dire de différentes
personnes racisées à différents degrés
d'intégration en France et euh et c'est
comme ça que qui a commencé à se
dessiner mon et mon histoire et euh et
voilà et comme moi j'ai j'ai
l'impression d'avoir d'être tout tout
simplement touché par le sujet pour
diverses raisons d'abord par le fait de
je pense mes origines multiples qui même
si elles ne sont pas visibles et donc
c'est toute la différence parce que j'ai
jamais souffert du racisme il n'empche
la cleur de poau en tout cas voilà il il
n'empêche que que que j'ai grandi aussi
dans un quartier à la fois populaire et
et
très multiculturel qui était le 18e
arrondissement euh vers voilà entre on
va dire entre blanche et et barbess et
eu et qui était et qui qui est ma vision
à moi de la société française et qui est
donc une société mélangée multiethnique
avec et et c'est ce qui fait toute sa
richesse et voilà mes amis moi j'ai
jamais souffert du racisme mais
évidemment beaucoup d'amis qui ont
souffert et donc c'est c'est quelque
chose qui me qui ouis qui qui m'a
toujours porté touché et interpellé je
me souviens d'avoir donc ma passion
étant le théâtre d'aller
à la fois découvrir des œuvres ados de
Peter Brook Arian nchkin qui qui eux-mêm
mettaient des des des des castings
divers variés venant de chaque pays
chaque univers qui avait une grande
inclusion dans leur spectacle et à la
fois d'aller aussi découvrir des œuvres
dans le théâtre privé où à la fois sur
scène et dans la salle ben il y avait
pas de personne racisé il y avait que
des blancs et moi ça me choquait parce
que c'était pas du tout ce que j'avais
comme vision de la France donc depuis le
débutin j'essaie de d'avoir un d'avoir
des des des acteurs qui sont de
d'origine diverse et pas justement on
avait une question on avait la même
question avec on se posa la question
c'est des c'est des anciens migrants
c'est des migrants ou c'est des ACT des
vrais
comédiens comm n oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai ça aurait pu ça aurait pu non non
c'est ce sont des des comédiens que je
connais pour la plupart ils sont SEP il
y en a cinq avec qui j'ai déjà travaillé
trois sur intramuros deux sur le porteur
d'histoire et de nouveaux Kevin Raz et
manda Touré que j'ai rencontré qui
viennent tous de d'horizons différents
de diff diff sont qui sont tous des
comédiens et et des comédiennes et et et
c'est assez joli parce que c'est une
c'est une troupe ouais multiculturelle
il y a voilà Jean-Louis il est
martiniqué isman elle est marocaine
feissal aussi manda elle est d'origine
malienne il y a chacun amène ses ses ses
origines mais euh voir une une troupe
aussi diverse sur une scène de théâtre
privé aussi aussi belle que la
Renaissance c'est c'est quelque chose de
suffisamment rare pour pour pour en être
fier c'est c'est une pièce qui est
politiquement engagée vous vous
l'assumez vous vous d'être un de faire
un peu de la politique quelque part bah
je vous avoue que moi je j'ai j'ai j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais pas un militant
mais si la raison pour laquelle je suis
pas militant c'est parce que j'ai
l'impression d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes dès que je dis quelque chose de
politique euh après j'ai toujours été de
gauche ça a toujours été mes convictions
depuis le début et ça ça a pas changé
c'està-dire que voilà mon ma ma pensée
politique elle est elle est assez claire
l'endroit où je me situe est assez clair
euh il se trouve que ce sujet-là euh
forcément me pousse à me positionner à
un moment mais ce qui est mais ce qui
est ce qui est ce qui est presque
terrible et ironique et paradoxal c'est
que ce que je raconte dans cette pièce
pour tous mes potes de ma génération
c'est pas quelque chose de
révolutionnaire c'est quelque chose de
simple et d'acquis pour pour déjà pour
tous les comédiens de mon âge on fait
partie à peu près de la même mouvance
tous les les acteurs de théâtre ils sont
globalement tous à gauche et et donc et
et donc il y a quelque chose où où pour
nous c'est pas fou mais mais il y a 20
ans quand Jean-Marie Le Pen passait au
second tour on était un million dans les
rues aujourd'hui chaque élection bah on
a le RN qui passe comme une fleur au
deème tour et qui grignote chaque fois
de plus en plus de voix et et voilà et
on a la mém ça veut dire que vous vous
voulez faire des des spectacles des des
mises en scène qui soient plus engagé
maintenant c'est pas c'est pas ça non
non non c'est chaque chaque chaque œuvre
sur voilà et sa propre à sa propre
identité mais là c'est un peu le hasard
que ce soit tombé en plein débat sur
l'immigration au Parlement en fait j'ai
eu l'idée il y a 3 ans je l'ai écrite il
y a un an il se trouve qu'elle sort
vraiment très fortement avec l'actualité
qu'on a vécu ici à l'assemblé naoua mais
j'espère que la pièce elle va durer
longtemps et et et surtout bon j'espère
aussi que cette loi va pas passer mais
bon c'est une c'est une autre histoire
mais mais je surtout je je je pense que
c'est un sujet qui qui est presque
éternel c'est-à-dire que bon plus récent
évidemment parce que les les grandes
migrations ça commence au 19e siècle
mais et puis et puis surtout on a eu là
dans les années 70 toute l'immigration
nord-africaine qui a qui a qui a changé
le visage de la France parce que avant
ça dans les années 50 il y avait déjà
des migrations polonaises italiennes
Belg mais donc européennne et donc qui
qui qui se voyait moins et et le racisme
était peut-être moins fort néanmoins
mais mais mais mon mon père il a quand
dit dans les années 50 dans le Nord
voilà c'était les salles polaques et les
salalles ritales quoi donc il y avait
déjà il y avait déjà ce il y avait déjà
ce il y a un homme de gauche deuxème
gauche Michel Rocard qui disait on peut
pas accueillir toute la misère du monde
mais il faut y prendre sa part êaccord
avec avec ça dans la dans la dans la
pièce et Jean le personnage répond alors
déjà c'est c'est pas vraiment la misère
du monde parce que les pays les plus
pauvres envoient leurs travailleurs les
plus qualifiés hein et puis on peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
on pourrait certainement en accueillir
plus he le pourcentage d'immigrés en
France c'est 10 % la moyenne de l'OCDE
c'est-à-dire l'Europe et les États-Unis
donc les pays riches en gros c'est 13 %
le Canada l'Australie c'est 20 % donc on
en est loin vous regrettez que le RN
monte mais il monte en partie à cause de
la politique migratoire et à cause de
l'immigration est-ce que vous trouvez
que cette immigration elle est bien
gérée bien contrôlé en France moi je
encore une fois je je me réfère à ce que
je raconte dans la pièce parce que c'est
c'est je suis un auteur donc c'est c'est
c'est je me ma parole est là mais donc
je je vais reciter un peu ce que je dis
euh moi je pense que le le le le vrai
coupable c'est l'état et sa politique
d'intégration déplorable c'est-à-dire
que depuis toujours he pas pas pas là
récemment on a toujours eu des choix qui
étaient des choix terribles et qui n'ont
fait que continuer à diviser une opinion
euh la politique migratoire si elle
était
meilleur mieux pensé plus accueillante
plus intégrante donc vous dites plus
d'immigré vous ouais moi déjà moi je dis
mieux intégré mieux ACC av dit aussi
plus oui oui non mais oui plus
d'immigrés parce qu'on est condamné à
avoir plus d'immigrés parce que sinon on
a'ura pas de quoi payer les retraites
dans 20 ans donc l'immigration c'est une
source positive quoi qu'il en soit à
terme en revanche ce que je constate
c'est que moi le le pour moi le cœur du
problème ce n'est pas une question
d'immigration c'est une question
d'inéquité sociale pour moi c'est le
cœur de tous les problème et ça devrait
être à mon sens hors hors débat sur sur
l'écologie et la planète qui est je mets
dans une case à part mais ça devrait
être le le seul sujet qui devrait être
traité tout le temps H24 pour tout le
monde je pense que c'est la source de
tous les mots l'in équité social je
pense que ça devrait être en fait je
tout le reste pour moi c'est de la
tartuferie c'està-dire c'est des
procédés politiques pour dire non non
non mais parlons pas d'équité sociale
parlons plutôt des des des immigrés
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des immigrés
laissez laissez cours à votre racisme
allez alimentons mettons dehuile sur le
feu parlons plutôt des conflits parlons
plutôt de gérarde pardieu pendant de
semaines et faisons passer la loi
immigration discrètement en fait moi
pour moi l'inéquité sociale elle elle ne
vient pas desimmigrés elle vient de
cette politique elle vient de cette
politique qui fait que ben en fait ils
sont condamnés à à mettre deux ou trois
générations avant de pouvoir espérer en
une amélioration de leurs conditions
l'inéquité sociale c'est ce qui fait
c'est ce qui fait que la que la pauvreté
et et que le les écarts de richesse
s'accroissent et quand les écarts de
richesse saccroissent la grogne monte la
colère monte et aujourd'hui le RN il
récupère tout simplement le vote ouvrier
hein donc aujourd'hui alors que qui a
été délaissé par la gauche qui a été
délaissé par la gauche bien sûr et alors
qu'on a une on a on a on a des écarts de
richesse de plus en plus importants il y
a plus de gauche pour fédérer et il y a
personne pour mais attendez le le
problème est-ce que ce serait pas juste
de de de mieux répartir les richesses
d'avoir moins de colère et de pouvoir
avoir une société plus juste et plus
intégrante envers les minorités les les
les plus atteintes et voilà moi pour moi
c'est des choses qui me semblent
évidentes alors ça c'était pour la
partie très politique on va parler
maintenant du dry January qui touche à
sa fin vous allez pouvoir ressortir les
bouteilles d'alcool à moins que à moins
que vous ne décidiez de ne plus y
toucher si la consommation d'alcool
baisse près de 24 % des 1825 ans
dépassent les repères de consommation on
en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat une nouvelle tendance les
sobreliers il remplac les somelier et
prôent comme leur nom l'indique la
sobriété donc pas d'alcool mais des
boissons à base de plantes ou de fruits
elles attirent de nouveaux adeptes avec
des menus dégustation d'un nouveau genre
Hélène Bonduel et Marion de Vauchel ont
tenté cette expérience culinaire
regardez premier sobrevage pour
accompagner cette première séquence là
il s'agit de l'eau de cacahuète grillée
des pommes fermenté sur un Levin
d'olive c'est vraiment surprenant est
très très B très très dou c'est beaucoup
moins fort que ce que je pensais et
c'est un bel accompagnement deuxème ce
breuage
percollation de sarrasin grillé ce
soir-là les clients de ce restaurant
expérimentent un menu dégustation un peu
spécial un accord mais et boisson non
alcoolisé général on a tout de suite un
petit peu d'acidité ou une une note un
petit peu plus haute du vin par rapport
au plat là non c'est c'est vraiment le
plat qui est exané par rapport au
par rapport à la boisson c'est un choix
de de de de faire le drive J et puis de
choisir un restaurant qui nous
accompagne dans cette dans ce parcours
ces breuvages c'est Benoît de nfriot
lui-même qui les élabore des
fermentations des macérations de fruits
et céréales des infusions de légumes de
pain et d'épices somelier depuis 13 ans
il est devenu ce qu'il appelle un
soubrelier il m'est apparu de plus en
plus insupportable d'être une figure de
restaurant exclusive à à une portion de
gens qui peuvent boire de l'alcool
sachant que depuis que je fais ce métier
j'ai toujours été confronté à des
personnes qui ne buvaient pas d'alcool
je me suis rendu compte que je n'avais
pas prêté attention à cette clientèle là
une clientèle de plus en plus nombreuse
le marché des boissons sans alcool a
augmenté de 13 % l'an dernier bonjour
est-ce que je peux vous renseigner moi
j'aime bien le j'aime bien le souign je
pense que je vais essayer
cette boutique propose 500 références de
boissons toutes sans aucun alcool vousz
tout ce qui est plutôt cocktail ici pour
Leser refaire vousmême du jean du sprit
du R de la Mareto et puis plein de
création original à base de plantes ou
autre je viens chercher un cadeau pour
un ami qui boit un peu trop d'alcool
donc je pense qu'il sera assez content
d'avoir une bouteille une bonne
bouteille sans alcool qui puisse
apprécier du plaisir quoi sans s la
gueule de bois
après mais ces boissons onell vraimentû
comm vin blanc désalcoolisé par exemple
B je suis assez surprise en fait ENF
effectivement il y a pas la longueur en
bouche mais la première ggé c'est assz
ça ressemble quand même pas mal à une
version originale vous pourriez tenter
de faire un repas avec ce vin par
exemple oui ça ça pourrait être une une
expérience peut-être si ça me permettait
de boire moins d'alcool et un transfert
tout en ayant le plaisir mais baisser ma
consommation d'alcool je pense que ça
serait une bonne chose c'est un peu mon
idée à la base c'était de dire voilà moi
j'aime j'ai plus envie de boire l'alcool
et en même temps j'aime continuer à
aller dans les bars les restaurants
sortir avec des amis en dîner et cetera
et on est toujours limité à un jus de
fruits à des sodas super secré et
surtout proposer un nouveau récit donc
sortir du sang alcool qui est toujours
un peu triste punitif limité à la
sécurité routière et cetera et le
concept fonctionne le patron envisage
même d'ouvrir de nouvelles boutiques en
France alors vous Alexis mich accords m
20 120 vous connaissez puisque vous êtes
Dr toute l'année j'ai bien compris moi
je suis zéro alcool ça vous tente ces
concoctions on va goûter c'est le chef n
préaime pas le vin et ça c'est du vin
donc voyez dans le
reportage alcoolisé ouais très bien ok
très bien non pas plus que ça vous aimez
pas trop non mais j'aime pas le vin moi
donc
du ah oui il y a l'odeur un pe alors il
a un peu le nez du
vin est alors après on boucheors celui-l
on y va attention ça
ça c'est le sabrelier qui l'
concoté il y a surtout du CL GIR du clou
girofle attention dégustation a beaucoup
de clou de girofle il a beaucoup de clou
GIR ouais c'est une c'est une concoction
à base de clou de girofle ouais ça
c'était censé accompagner le couscous
d'accord d'accord très bien c'est pour
ça auss il faut le voir accord mais
vin PL bah faut aimer le clou de girof
quoi et vraiment aimz beaucoup le clouof
je suis assez de la VI du clouofle c'est
peut-être un peu trop clou de girof pour
moi très clou GIR moi je préfère le vin
à la rigueur mais à consommer avec
modération Jean-Pierre n'est-ce pas
est-ce que je peux attaquer le dessert
ou pas encore alors on va commencer le
dessert puisque non mais c'est
intéressant ces boissons C renouveau du
sans alcool aussi peut-être de voir ses
vins c'est vous vous sentez peut-être un
peu moins seul maintenantécole qui qui
donc jamais peux vous dire je je vois
très bien ce qu'il veut dire quand il
dit quand il dit bah dans les bars
qu'est-ce qu'on boit et c'est vrai qu'on
a assez peu de choix moi je serais pro
infusion été c'est le c'est le mieux
pas un verre puisque je ne bois pas
d'alcool donc mais vous YZ pas quand
même pour prendre un thé si évidemment
mais il y a pas de thé enfin th chaud
mais il faudrait toute une gamme de trè
th froid c'est très facile à produire et
c'est ce qui coûte le moins
cher ce genre ah oui moi je serai pour
le et puis surtout de sans sucre sans
sucre c'est ça le plus important alors
tout le monde a fini on passe au dessert
et c'est le PCH
mignon moi j'attaque on va aller très
vite parce que ch voulaz juste une
salade de fruits de saison je ne sais
pas il y a des kiwi il y a des petits
raisins qui ressemblent à des olives il
y a des pommes vous n'aimez pas les
desserts n'im pas les gâteaux j'aime pas
les dessers vous parz des baclava moi
j'aurais préféré fassiez goûter les
baclavas PL c'est que j'aime trop les
desserts c'est pour ça mais oui c'est
que j'essaie de me de me maintenir dans
une dans voilà dans un dans un mode de
vie niveau de poids correct c'est le Dra
mais jusqu'au dessert le c'est Plô le Dr
sugar c'est j'ess éviter le sucre parce
que effectivement bon bah le sucou aimz
beaucoup les desserts en fait vous
freinez freinez justement mais là voilà
depuis bah depuis janvier là j'ai je
fais ma cure ma cure sans sucre donc les
fructoses oui pourquoi pas évidemment
mais mais j'essayie alors si vous avez
le droit on oublie le Dra et tout
qu'est-ce que vous aimez comme dessert
mais tout la profitrol les baclaval les
desserts moi les pâtisseries marocaines
je suis complètement fan le tout ce qui
est tout tout tout quoi enfin on a la
chance en plus de Vire en France quand M
B pâtissier chaque boulangerie on a à
peu près tout ce qu'il nous faut non
voilà je je j'aime tout le sucre moi je
je les je peux manger des cookies mais
je j'amenais des cookies à mes comédiens
pendant les répétitions et cetera mais
après je le vois je le vois on est tous
mal on en souffrance quel est votre
secret parce que vous êtes fit hein ah
voilà la salade de fruit mais c'est bien
vu une salade de fruit à un couscous moi
je dis il a rison jou même chez les
fruits normalement il vaut mieux les
consommer entre les repas que à la fin
d'un repas puisque quand on les consomme
à la fin d' repas il il il fermente un
peu et donc il se digère moins bien mais
bon on termine toujours cette émission
en musique vous avez choisi celle-là on
[Musique]
l'écoute alors l'histoire de cette
musique a un lien avec passeport c'est
slly Johnson qui est un musicien éérite
talentueux beatbxeer qui touche à tout
et qui était un un ancien du Sayan
spacro et que j'ai vu faire à l'occasion
des musiques de pièces et je suis allé
le voir en lui disant est-ce que
çaéresse de faire la musique de
passeport il a il a lu le texte et il
m'a dit oui oui ça me plaît donc il
était avec nous en répétition tous les
jours et il a composé toute la BO de
passeport et ça c'est en regardant vos
répétitions exactement et et ça c'est la
chanson finale qu'on qui monte sur les 5
dernières minutes et qui est qui arrive
jusqu'aux applaudissements et vraiment
c'est je pense qu'il va la mettre
bientôt en ligne sur VO la faire écouter
à nos téléspectateurs et on va se
quitter sur cette cette belle chanson
euh cette belle musique Merci à VOUS
Alexis michalic d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans politique à table merci
à vous tous de nous avoir suivi merci
Jean-Pierre et on se retrouve bien sûr
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à Tab sur
[Musique]
LCP